passoires énergétiques le retour après à
partir de 2028 les logements classés f
et g ne pourront plus être loués mais
pour le commun des mortels faire
diagnostiquer et isoler son logement
coûtent encore très cher alors pour les
aider la comcom touraine est vallée a
fait passer leur maison sous l'oeil des
caméras thermiques le résultat en bleu
et en rouge avec romain delville dans la
nuit noire froide et obscur régis martel
prend la température des murs à l'affût
de la déperdition de chaleur
pour cela il dispose d'une caméra pas
comme les autres c'est une caméra flir
portative qui permet de pouvoir faire de
l'acquisition en infrarouge dans
différentes gammes et ensuite une fois
que les acquisitions a été effectué et
donc par cette caméra
le bureau géomatique de notre société
action à l'environnement va traiter et
classifié c'est différent de l'image
afin d'en sortir un rendu en six niveaux
de couleurs plus tôt dans l'année un
avion équipé d'une caméra infrarouge a
survolé les dix communes de la comcom
touraine est vallée pour effectuer une
thermographie du secteur en résulte un
site internet où se superposent une vue
satellite et les résultats de
déperdition énergétique plus ces bleus
plus l'isolant est bon c'est assez
flagrant sur des gros bâtiment où il ya
une grande surface on voit nettement des
partis qui sont corrects
enfin là elle est il y avait quelque
chose à faire surtout de bâtiments mais
si on zoome sur celui ci ou celui ci on
voit que là il ya un local qui
manifestement est pas bien traité
l'isolation est pas bonne qualité tandis
que le reste est bon donc là il faut il
faut accentuer les efforts sur cette
partie de la maison
avec ce site plus possible de nier les
problèmes d'isolation de certaines
maisons ou de certains bâtiments
l'idée c'est ensuite de guider les
habitants vers des solutions de travaux
nous sommes en actuellement en train de
travailler avec trois autres communautés
de communes amboise blairer
château-renault pour mettre en place une
plateforme de rénovation énergétique et
si nous arrivons à bien mettre en place
cette plateforme
les habitants pourront regarder
sur le site comment et isoler leur
maison et ensuite s'adresser cette
plateforme pour avoir des conseils des
adresses de façon à se lancer dans une
véritable politique de rénovation de
leur propre habitat l'argument est
autant écologique et économique avec le
prix de l'énergie qui ne cesse de
grimper
ce qui est bon pour la planète les
maintenant aussi pour le porte-monnaie